white sox and orioles game number four
sox are going for the four-game sweep
against baltimore cedric mullins can hit
a fastball he's hitting 448.
oh is it gonna there's strike three
one down very quickly for any of these
hitters who haven't seen lucas you can
look on video as long as you want to you
just can't get the feel of this straight
chain and what you can't get is the
delivery that g leto has because it
looks just like his fastball and then
you swinging the ball doesn't get there
yeah home run and a big hit on thursday
night so kevin keegan aiken same same
age as uh lucas giovalito here are the
numbers lefties over 400 right he's kind
of where you want him to be and almost
hit in 280s
he got him so a nice first inning for
keegan aiken gets him one two three and
ends it with a strikeout dj stewart will
hit with no one on and one down against
lucas giolito
that's tagged
way back in right field
and dj steward out for a home run
he went up and got one
pitch up high stewart takes it out and
the orioles have a one-nothing lead well
there keegan there's your run lucas
giolito was cruising along until dj got
an elevated pitch and he smashed it to
right and stuart that ends an old for 10
hitler stretch for him as he got a
fastball that was up in the strike zone
got on top of it short to the baseball
which he needs to be and good start for
the o's and now here he is again billy
hamilton leads off to third
hamilton drills this ball did he do it
again the answer is yes
oh billy the hitter
back-to-back games
billy don't you lose that number 1-1
in the third
well the end part of that staple is
going to be he was brought here because
he could pinpoint and play defense
the bat is a plus
another home run
[Music]
it's tied at one and
you can tell his teammates are enjoying
this almost as much as billy is
that was a line drive rocket
a no doubt home run
just crushed
and they're going to start chanting
billy again when he goes out there to
center i do believe in a year of really
good stories for the white sox billy
hamilton is one of those wonderful
stories giolito to stevie wilkerson 1-1
tie fifth inning
cold strike three into the attic a
change up and a fierce punch out from
surewater lookers it up twice strikes
out twice thought this was a walk it
came down nice job by collins you take
the high pitch like that and watch what
you do with the glove you're taking the
glove down before you move your arm and
by taking it down it doesn't show as
much movement that was well framed and
he bought the strike 3-2
to nevin swinging a miss strike three
fastball beat
him nine strikeouts and now lucas has
struck out four of the last five batters
face
lucas has got that focus he's got that
march around the mound too after the
strikeout
you can see the intensity when he's
having a run like this he's feeling it
two strikes on stewart fifth inning a
one-one tie
and the pitch hole
swinging a miss strike three
lucas strikes out the side he's just
walking off he was ready to go when he
threw the pitch that is a laser coming
out of his eyes right there ten
strikeouts for lucas giolito they went
to plutko who just walked to bray when
they're loaded up
1-1 pitch line drive snared by galvez
deep short throws to second and they got
him what a play by freddy galvez that's
the second big play he's made in this
game and none bigger than that as he
scooped one up in the hole at shortstop
threw on his second lucas 10 strikeouts
20 swings and misses his career high and
swings and misses is 30. 68 pitches only
severino went around that strike three
11 strikeouts
six of the last seven batters have been
strikeouts
getting pretty amazing this changeup
just dives at the end sabrina cannot
check it up
there you see the grip there you see the
sink there you see the departing battery
oh two
struck him out
three straight change-ups
lucas conkers santander but he saves the
best for last because this one just dove
out of the zone he's ahead he knows he
can toy with the strike zone but throws
it in literally the perfect spot season
high and strikeouts one off of his
career high of 13.
2-0 to madrigal tim at first there he
goes madrigal
that's strike one i don't believe he
made contact with the ball so tim's got
second base
he's in pretty good shape to accomplish
what tony lewis are wanting to
accomplish is moving tim along to third
90 feet farther now tim starts to take
off throwback to second ends up in
center field tim's going for third
mullins has no play
tim anderson made that happen
he alarmed the pitcher tate and there he
goes to third with nobody else there is
a lot of room to hit it through and
bloop it over the head of the pulled in
infield
handle right field santander
doesn't get there
nikki two strikes gives the sox the lead
that's off the net so it's still in play
it's a triple three bases for nikki two
strikes and a 2-1 lead
he has hit a couple of missiles this
afternoon i gotta believe when you're
looking at the guy who profiles as a
two-hitter in today's game
you're looking at the guy that just
tripled down the line nick is going to
make some contact it's his second hit he
drives in a run
he puts the socks on top and this one
slicing away from santander who had very
little chance to get it and now the
infield's going to come in and
absolutely pay for it
sears one to center and it's three to
one that's yuan's second hit of the day
and the top of the lineup is getting it
done one drives in run number 29 after
nikki drives in run number 16
and a first ball fastball goes right
back where it came from
steve you you can't miss down to montana
if you're gonna throw up a passport not
these days
and the orioles are down to their final
chance it's wilkerson with two outs
madrigal at second liam hendricks saves
another he did quick work
of the baltimore orioles and there is
the four-game sweep for the sox
and now with cleveland's result pending
the sox could be four and a half up
as they go to cleveland and bobby bigpin
was the last guy to do what liam did the
last 24 hours